(Trailer plays) "Just who, in the hell do you think you are?"
-Hey
everybody, it's Charlie.
So there's a whole bunch more he guardians 2 stuff dropping. James Gunn did this big Q&A where he dropped all kinds of teasers
And Infinity war, characters that he cut out of
the movie that I think, I know about.
So, I'm going to play this video then I'll explain
all the really big stuff.
There's a new round of the Spider-Man give-away.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
So, what I did is.. I cut this down to the really important
stuff. So, I'll play this that I'll explain
about the character that he cut out, the 3rd
Guardians film and Avengers infinity war-stuff
"I don't know if it's considered a spoiler ..If I say something which is in the trailer..
..But..of course the trailer features the song 'The Chain'- by Fleetwood Mac..
..which is.. one of my favorite songs of all
time off of one of my favorite albums of all time..
..a-a..nd ..-uhh and it's..-uhh..an important part of ..uhh..Guardians Of
The Galaxy Vol.2...
..We also get a first glimpse at Ayesha played by the wonderful Elizabeth
Debicki..
..Who you might know from The Night Manager for instance, uhh..
..She came in and auditioned for Ayesha and
she was so incredibly perfect that ..I only..
..Who was also AMAZING !!..
..I wouldn't say who that is.. but I only addition
two people for Ayesha..
..because Elizabeth came in and.. it was like she was born to play this
role...
..in the role of dragster how I felt about complementary
up in the role of mantis, it's like these people
..I wouldn't say who that is.. but I only addition
two people for Ayesha..
..because Elizabeth came in and.. it was like she was born to play this
role...
..It's very much..HOW I felt about Dave Bautista..
..in the role of dragster how I felt about Pom Klementieff in the role of mantis, it's like these people..
..were born to play those roles and it's-..it's
nothing as more exciting than finding those..
..types of-.. ..-of the making of tak-.. those types of casting
choices and finding those actors out there..
..So, anyway.. what you guys think? I'm turning
on my sink again, my worries are that there will be too many..
..Guardians to get into a really good story
with them all. Okay, So, here's what I promise..
..you.. my promise to you the fans is that every
Guardian will be...You know..
..receiving much more personal attention than in the last film...
..Every Guardian has their own unique story,
their own unique character arc...
..They each learn something, maybe good maybe
bad, as they travel on this journey..
..This is a story that is truly about all The
Guardians Of The Galaxy..
..There's one thing we found from.. you know.. stra-..Test Screens..
..stories of all The Guardians and.. the way they
work together and.. first story was mostly the..
..story of Chris Pratt as.. -uhh.. playing Peter Quill
of the story Peter Quill (AKA)Star-Lord..
..the second movie is a story of all of The Guardians together it
really does each get their own piece of the..
..pie.. and I think each of them are able to shine
and ..-aa..aa-nd..it's-....-it's been a marvelous experience..
..to put it all together and that way-... As of you may
know I had a much longer time to write the..
..screenplay for The Guardians Of The Galaxy Vol.2
than I did for The Guardians Of The Galaxy Vol.1...
..I was in a 'lil rush when ..I had to write the
first one...
..So, I'm really proud of the movie...
..I'm happy with the way it turned out, but
I think that the second film is a much more intricately..
..plotted film with a lot more exciting things
in and just more unique in that way..
..HOW ..DID I DECIDE on the new character additions mantis, Ayesha..
..Well, How did I decide?, I mean.. I just really like
the character of mantis and she fit in..
..As..I've told people before it's no secret..
..I originally added two Guardians. As I was saying,
I originally added 2 characters to..
..My initial treatment
had to new characters to The Guardians new characters..
..there's plenty of new characters Ayesha there's
ego...
..There's Taser face but I just I felt like
after I went through that the treatment I..
..felt like there were too many characters...
..Frank and I do think that there's anything
that so many movies have been suffering from..
..its just too many characters, even the comic
books when I read comic books today there's..
..often too many characters...
..Not each character doesn't get their own story
and so that's why again I promise you each..
..character is given specific special attention
about who they are...
..I would not have included them if they didn't
fit in in a very specific and special way..
..that goes all the way to characters like crackling
young use first making Taser face and you...
..know these other characters....
..But yeah so mantis is just somebody I really
liked a lot there was another character that..
..used to be in the script to I took out who...
..Hopefully, you know, will be in a future marble
movie, you guys are asked me about characters..
..I could could ever show up star...
..Often people like this and you know that's
that's that's that's that's always possible..
..somebody says in the infinity stones...
..There is no infinity stones guardians the
galaxy value to it is a separate story which..
..is about the characters within guardians...
..It's about you know Ayesha and who she is
and it's about Peter Quill's relationship..
..with his father and and that's really what
the movie is about it is not about power stone...
...is not about forwarding the larger story of
the Marvel universe...
..It really is its own thing...
..Its own separate fable any big Easter egg
plant...
..Volume 2 yes I have plenty of Easter eggs
and value to as many as are in volume 1 probably..
..I think...
..So we have a lot of Easter eggs in the movement...
...So I hope you guys enjoy that watching it
is and I know a lot of you are people who...
...watch guardians of the galaxy...
...Not one, not 2, not 10, but 50 60 times and
so giving you these guys Easter eggs...
..This is a lot of fun for me whether there
Easter eggs having to do with you know the..
..marvel universe or you know other movies or
or anything...
...Can I drop in just about any more songs on
the volume 2 soundtrack well I mean, you could...
..check out any a lot of people know that there's
a chance that Jay and the Americans, little..
...bit closer is in the movie because it is a
song that was played with the scene that we...
...showed both at the Brazil, con and at San
Diego comic con this year....
...So please read volume 3 well we will have
to see any chance for bated re-bill Easter...
..egg...
...I don't know who knows love tracks more Drexel
of all sorts of Drexel of coming in here in..
...the comments is another marble movie you would
do besides guardians of the galaxy I don't..
..know who knows...
...I mean I really love the cosmic side of the
universe...
...I really I love Marvel superheroes, but I
I've made guardians if you consider guardians...
...is a superhero film is now made for superhero
films but will interest me more about guardians..
..galaxy is not the superhero aspect what interest
me is the space opera aspect, it's more of..
..a science fiction space opera film to me in
so that's what that's what is really interesting..
..to me right now and that's kind of you want
to make more so than a superhero movie...
..So, so, are there superheroes...
..I love yes I talked about the superheroes
of love I love moon night...
...I love the thunderbolts I look at monkey not
exactly at superheroes was a lot of marble...
..of squirrel girl, there's a lot of superheroes...
...I really love I love shazam I love Batman
the music...
..These all characters that are great but, but
I'm not sure you know what I want to do right..
..now...
...I love making is more than that, though I've
committed the past three years of my life..
..to making guardians the galaxy value to as
special in this beautiful and is wonderful..
..and is truthful as I possibly can and it's
it's at the end of a marathon for me and I..
..didn't have any involvement with infinity
war yes some executive producer on infinity..
...war of the working hard with the Russo brothers
with the Marvel guys and Kevin Feige to make..
...sure that any of the characters I'm involved
with that are in that movie are well taken..
..care of and are is as funny as they should
be and is is honest and truthful there should..
..be something dealing with them all the time
I've been talking to the actors onset every..
...single day is because as we go through per
foot production and the and it's been nice..
..been a great experience for how much focus
will Ayesha get in volume 2 she gets a lot..
..of focus...
..She's very, very important character and she's
a pretty bad film that I mean you know listen..
..nobody's hundred percent bad except for maybe
maybe Ron was sort of hundred 90 we many was..
..another present that he had his reasons for
doing what he did.."
(CHARLIE) -So the big thing the character that he cut
out of guardians of the galaxy to I think..
that's Cosmo I think.
Originally Cosmo was going to be on the team,
but mantis was the other new weird awesome
character he said they were just too many
things going on.
So maybe he'll make it into a future fellow
that's probably Cosmo you guys can let me
know in the comments though who do you think
that secret characters that he cut out was
now keep in mind that there probably a space-based
character, it's not an Earth-based avenger
and it's not a human he's always said that
Peter Quill is the only human on the guardians
of the Galaxy team.
He wanted to feel like a unique person in
outer space.
So whoever the character he cut out is it
some big deep cut and I just feel like that
all points to Cosmo because he was such an
awesome Easter egg from the first movie in
a really cool character who also travels with
the guardians in the comics.
The other big infinity war thing.
He confirmed as a producer on the film, working
closely with the Russo's mostly with his characters.
The guardians in the things that they're doing
during infinity war.
So they'll be a lot of his unique qualities
that you see in guardians the really amazing
visual look the music you will see during
infinity war if you like the music is the
biggest thing to that's one of the big things
that differentiates guardians of the other
Marvel films they all look great, but James
Gunn.
It just like a step above in terms of his
creative vision, but that actually reminds
me.
So he said no infinity gems, no power stone
because that still with the NOVA corps guardians
movie doesn't have anything to do with pushing
marbles phase 3 story forward.
So that you knwo Thantos infinity gauntlet ..so, that's
all relegated to Thor Ragnarok the other really
fun teaser is that he sounds more-and-more
like he's going to do a third Guardians film,
which I feel like we all felt was inevitable,
but early on before they release the first
trailer when they just finished filming.
He's like I don't know guys but whatever's
happened since then.
It just sounds like it's reenergized him like
he's so happy with the way the film is turned
out that he is totally down to do more with
these characters, we talked about the rocket
Groot spinoff film that's been talked about.
But it might actually end up being the basis
for the third guardians film.
So in the way the guardians to, doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with the Marvel phase
3 plot line the Thanos storyline.
The third guardians of rocket Groot movie
might also have the same relationship with
phase 4 because it probably wouldn't come
tomorrow phase 4.
Just because Doctor strange movie did amazing,
but Scott Derrickson said at Marvel so busy
they have so many films on their schedule
that Dr. Strange-2 .. isn't going to come anytime..soon..
But ..any of that could change let me know in the comments
But...any of that could change, let me know in the comments
What do you think about the idea of a Rocket and Groot movie ?
The other guardians would be in it.
But to be mostly their story as opposed to
Peter Quill story.
So what can happen next is as they drop some
new Logan footage there's the Legion TV show
that's premiering this week and we may have
a synopsis for X-Men supernova that secret
X-Men movie so I will do a video for that
next and there was this really cool Justice League preview
..they released..during the SUPERBOWL ..I'll do a breakdown for that later tonight
So another day of 3 videos.
There's just SOO much comic-book stuff happening this week
Giveaway, THO ...BM gaming, you win one of the Spiderman-Man action figures
Please, private-message me, on the back-end of my channel.
So, I can get your contact details!.
It's a pre-order so they haven't started selling them yet,..But they're gonna be rolling them out REALLY SOON ..
Before the Spider-Man movie comes out.
So, there was a new round that started in this
video.
I'll announce the winner the next time I post a Marvel-video
There's gonna be A WHOLE..BUNCH OF STUFF happening this week
So, I'll try to post videos..AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
Thank you, SOOO..MUCH FOR WATCHING I'LL SEE YOU GUYS IN THE NEXT VIDEO!..
Click HERE < to watch the Guardians trailer;
And click here > for Stranger Things season 2 trailer